hallo annina ucatis wenn ich genau
richtig aussprechen
also ich habe eine frage zu big brother
da ich hörte dass du 2009 im big
brother-haus warst ich höre eigentlich
oft schlechtes von rtl2 dass sie zum
beispiel bei frontrange ihre wohnung
verfügen um dann zu sagen dass die
wohnungen und dreckig ist und so was
alles also dass frauen quasi gefegt ist
und ja da wollte ich eigentlich nur
wissen ob es
ob es im big brother-haus rechten dingen
zuging
also läuft ja alles ab wie es wirklich
ist jetzt wenn da irgendwas passiert
oder werden manche sachen auch
inszeniert um die zuschauer zum beispiel
eine spannung zu halten oder sowas ja
ich wollte einfach mal wissen wie es
wirklich im big brother haus zugeht da
kann ich ja einmal fragen die wirklich
dabei war und meine zweite frage ist was
alles was arbeiterin heute eigentlich
also irgendwas muss man ja arbeiten und
ich weiss ich könnte eigentlich googeln
warst du arbeitest aber ich finde da
immer nur ein beruf und zwar wegen
dieser berufe mit porno darstellerin
bringt mir nicht viel zu seinem heutigen
beruf ich habe gehört dass auf gehabt
mit diesem beruf und da wollte ich
einfach mal fragen was für den beruf
hast du heute wenn du nicht aufpasst
falls das nicht zu privat ist hoffe ich
du beantwortest mainfranken und dann sag
ich mal tschüss und danke für die
beantwortung so also im big brother haus
ist tatsächlich so dass man keinen
kontakt zur außenwelt hat und dass
selbst ich obwohl ich ja damals gefragt
wurde ob ich einziehen möchte nicht weiß
was auf uns zukommen aber man muss
natürlich sagen es ist fernsehen und
dieser tages zusammenschnitt der dann
irgendwie um 19 uhr doch wann auch immer
läuft ist natürlich vom sender zusammen
geschnitten und die können natürlich
gewisse dinge auch so steuern durch
matches oder durch spezielle aktionen im
haus oder vielleicht auch durch die
bewohner diese dann zusammen packen da
haben sie natürlich auch einen gewissen
spielraum böses sagen können
so und so wird sich das ganze dann
entwickeln aber ansonsten ist es
definitiv nicht gefällt